I haven't started with questions from
Twitter before but I feel like they kind
of covered some of the initial ones I
wanted to go go off with uh-huh so maybe
we should just go with those all right
so the first one was from Ben Thompson
and he asked for more detail on the pay
to leave San Francisco yes I think you
guys called the D location yeah how's it
going
well we introduced this D location
package I think it was in in March and
the concept for those of you who aren't
familiar was if you're in the Bay Area
and you take a job with zap here will
pay $10,000 to help you relocate to
anywhere so we call it deal ok this was
this was an idea that one of our
engineers came up with because we'd seen
in interviews with folks from the Bay
Area they would come to zap here because
we're a hundred percent remote and say
like oh I'm interested in y'all in part
because I like the product but also
because you know this remote thing helps
me get away from San Francisco because
I'm either disenfranchised with you know
housing costs here or like I have family
somewhere else that I'd rather be living
with or I just want to be somewhere else
so you know of a bunch of reasons right
and and so what this the engineer on our
team kind of hypothesized is like well
maybe there's this nascent demand here
in the Bay Area where folks who are like
kind of just putting up with it because
that's this is where the jobs are and
he's like there's probably some folks
who are kind of on the fence that like
if a good opportunity came along they
might be willing to jump on that but
maybe they just need like a little bit
of a nudge to go do this sort of thing
and so that's where like the whole idea
of this deal location package came it's
not that crazy like plenty of companies
here on the Bay Area even like will pay
relocation cost to help you move here
sort of like well let's just turn it on
its head and say women hope you move
anywhere right so much that I think it
was a march and the funny thing was
since then we've seen probably about
roughly about a 30 percent increase in
applicants to zapier Wow so pretty
significant yeah we have hit with that
like our rolls routinely get 100 200
applicants some rolls we've even had I
think our record is like 1500 a fluke
for one open position and it'll signal
like those are there 30% increase in my
quality candor yes yes just across the
board and one of the interesting things
we noticed was the applicants weren't
actually from San Francisco however just
from wherever the heck they were and so
it was clear that the the like offering
this thing you know got it caught some
buzz and like mainstream media and so it
kind of just elevated the profiles
happier and so folks were like even who
weren't in the Bay Area we're like this
is just seems like a cool company like I
they have the same x values that I have
they are working on an interesting
product and so we got a lot of great
applicants from outside the area again
so we've actually hired about 15 folks
since then and only one person from the
Bay Area she's in the process of like
mulling over whether she wants to take
it or not but so we actually I'm going
to offer any cuz we don't hired any
folks out there yeah have you located
then II went to the Bay Area
through Annie I know was moved here so
we're way up that's really funny
and do you guys ever do relocations
other than not generally like most folks
are where they want to be or like their
head in that way anyway yeah so like
that's I mean that's kind of the beauty
of remote work is that you don't have to
live in a place just because that's
where the jobs are you can live in the
place that you want to be because that's
just where you want to be you know
you've got family there you got friends
there you've got life there you got a
hobby there you've got you just want to
explore the area because you've heard
cool things like it doesn't matter what
the reason is right like you can do that
mm-hmm and so how often are you actually
interacting with that many employees
here you guys were at about 95 okay how
often are you interacting with you know
a significant percentage of them in
person uh well in person we do so we did
this thing called air be an onboarding
which when we hire folks within the
first month we actually do like to have
them spend a week in person out here in
the Bay Area so will Lawrence and Airbnb
will bring their manager out here them
out here and then spend a week working
alongside them so generally it ends up
being like anywhere from like a half
dozen to a dozen folks out here at a
time
and it works really nicely because the
founders are all here so we get to sit
down next to them and even you know the
95th person in the company we get to
know really well like we'll spend the
night like take them out to dinner we'll
play games with them like we'll talk to
them about why the role is important at
the company like why we're happy that
they're here and they get like a full
week with us which is like pretty rare
at you know once you pass like a certain
amount of employees like maybe you'll do
like a lunch with the founders like
right out the gate but it's not in that
much time so we actually like really
spend a lot of time with them you know
within that first month for the for
those first folks so you know we do get
to spin like a fair amount of time with
a subset of folks every month so
basically week every month I'm spending
some time in person with a few people on
the team okay and so do you think that
your success as a remote team is a
function of you starting remote or do
you think you could have shaped into
that I think it definitely helped a lot
to start it that way I think it would be
pretty tough to transition any sizable
team to like a remote or partial remote
setup because there's just like little
cultural habits that you get into that
are that make remote kind of successful
so we started after as a side project
side projects naturally you don't have
offices you just work on them when you
can
which is not necessarily in-person it's
at a coffee shop or your house or
whatever right and so we got used to
working through like pull requests and
on Trello cards and in chat and things
like that and so that built up kind of
our organizational muscle for like
documenting things writing down like
processes and stuff like that so then
when you hire folks on they're able to
like adopt that stuff when you're in an
office you up to a certain point you can
kind of ignore that stuff because you
have the option of tapping someone on
the shoulder and being like hey you know
what's the looks like a man that I need
to do for this again or like what why is
this not working to help me do you know
whatever it is that you need help with
you can just pull folks into but for us
like you know if you're working with a
teammate halfway across the world like
that's not an option so you kind of have
to get good at like hey here's like the
readme
you for this stuff and make sure that's
all up to Dayton and working pretty well
so yeah I think had we have like started
you know ten people in an office and
then added remote folks like we sure
certainly could have gotten there I know
companies that have done that but I
think it's just that you know you have
to unlearn some stuff and then relearn
it in a different way whereas we just
learned it that way from the get-go it
was there a point at which like you guys
were scaling up and you're like oh we're
we've entered like a different class of
like remote team size and we have to
handle things differently yeah
definitely um they're not and it's not
too different I think from even in look
it like co-located companies have like
those inflection points to or you're
like we need to change some stuff up
because it's not working and so for us
like the there's about three of them
where we've kind of had to really not
reinvent ourselves start to rethink a
few things so the first one was around
like 20 people which was up until that
point like I was the sole manager but
like not really management like when
it's less than 20 everything kind of
self happened so like me and Brian and
Mike my co-founders were just kind of
making sure things that happened once we
got to about 20 or so it's like actually
they're starting to be some coordination
overhead we need to like think about
like maybe what a little bit of a
management structure starts to look like
and so Brian Mike and I started really
sharing those roles around there in a
little more formal matter then at about
40 it got 40 to 50 or so it got even
more complex and we added more managers
and then that was like the first time
where I was solely managing other
managers so that was like an interesting
transition as well you know the folks
that were like primarily hiring people
and onboarding folks were not
necessarily me anymore and a lot of
times it wasn't so that was kind of a
shift and so how like how does that work
then as a remote manager of managers
where you're like pro-tips having maybe
done it for several years now yeah I
think you've got a set like a you really
need to set like the values of what your
company is going to look like
so you know just the high-level things
that you care about you know for us it's
like we like folks who are like default
action get stuff done because you know
there's not someone sitting beside you
to help you out that's like a big thing
we like folks who are good writers and
could be transparent because that's
really important in a remote team we
like folks who have a lot of empathy and
are like really good just hopeful people
because you're working in slack and in
text all day so it's like you need to be
able to emphasize when maybe like a
sentence doesn't come off quite right or
like whatever like you Beck I know I
chose to say like they had good
intentions here this wasn't like meant
to be you know harsh to me or whatever
right so those are like important values
that we had that lend themselves well to
remote environments and once you have
that stuff and set in place you kind of
have you have to adopt some sort of like
management paradigm like how you
approach management I think a lot of
companies least in startups like the
tyent try to reinvent the wheel here I
think it's not probably a great idea
especially if you're growing really fast
it's there's not like a lot of good like
scientific back to research on like how
it would be a good manager like go find
the good stuff and learn that and just
just kind of just cargo cult adopt that
in your organization because it can be
way you're going to have like way less
problems than if you tried to like come
up with your new inventive management
structure alongside this other like new
inventive product market the thing that
you're trying to bring the market so
like we there's this podcast called
manager tools and they have like a
paradigm and we basically just said like
we're just going to use their philosophy
on how they go about stuff because we
they guide like 95% of a jive with us so
we were like we're going to just use
what they have and that helps get all
the managers that I was working with I
knew that they were following a similar
process that I would be following the
folks so that kind of raised like the
organizational like baseline for like
your experiences after is going to be at
least this good you might get a manager
that's like above and beyond and way
better but like hopefully we don't have
any like managers that are
just like bad when really really bad we
wanted folks to be at that baseline so
we made sure like they go through like
the training that they need to have and
kind of understand the values and how we
apply them and all that sort of stuff
and then that helps for me who's not you
know managing managers I kind of know
that they're they're doing following our
guidelines and stuff like that no okay
and so now that like you're you know
approaching a hundred people do you feel
that there's another inflection point
coming definitely around like definitely
so like we started hiring probably our
our default is to like we like to
promote folks from from within so
historically almost all of our folks who
have moved in like management positions
have been working at zapier for you know
six twelve months like a good chunk of
time which helps them like learn the
culture but they also like know the
product and the role and everything like
really really well and downside is you
know they're our new manager so they
have to learn some of that stuff but
that's not unteachable stuff and now
we're at a point where occasionally we
don't have someone ready to like promote
up and we have to hire in a new manager
so like that's a new challenge for us
now because you're bringing in someone
who's going to like guide a function or
a set of people who you know primary
experiences at other orgs which is not
necessarily a bad thing they bring in
great outside perspectives that have
been helpful but you also have to like
teach them the org while they're also
trying to teach other like train and
coach other people in the organizations
well so that's like an interesting
inflection point as well okay and you're
going through that right now yeah like
we've brought on a few you know outside
management folks now and you know it's
going pretty well but like there's like
anything like there's you know things
that you got to keep working on alright
so that so been asked like a multi-part
question he and like many of these
questions were common across Twitter
yeah so they want to ask you about
raising money so you guys are like
famous or infamous
for doing YC raising some money and then
never raising money again yeah
like I'm going to combine a couple
questions here so another person Matt
Sherman who actually wanted you to come
on the podcast from from the outer cut
out set he basically said why did why'd
you guys choose to go into I see if you
weren't planning to raise a lot of
capital after and maybe you were
planning to and like you didn't decide
yeah um well the primary reason we did
YC wasn't for the capital primary reason
we did YC was because we were from
Missouri relatively unknown and not
well-connected into the broader tech
ecosystem particularly for our product
which is integrations with other SAS
companies we were building a lot of
those relationships from scratch and YC
kind of helped us well we're just able
to plug into an existing network
basically so for us the network was
really valuable because you know then
when we went into partners at least
there was like some thread somebody who
said like oh yeah we know this team this
company like they're pretty good folks
like you shouldn't you should chat with
them even when you're really really
small like we were at the time and no
one really had any sort of reason
outside validation reason to believe in
us at other than like hey they've seemed
like they're building a cool product
right so for us like that was the
primary reason for doing YC the money
sure like okay it was nice right but you
know I don't think that was the primary
reason for us doing it and then you know
afterwards we did take a little bit of
money because when is just going to
start it like things cost money and like
if you don't have anything you haven't
figured out like a business model yet
like you know and if you're going to be
living in the Bay Area which we felt we
wanted to like try and stick around a
little bit because to help build up
those relationships it's just really
freaking expensive deliver so a little
bit of money helped us kind of get past
those early days when you know we just
weren't pulling in that much revenue and
you guys were priced a little bit
differently but like you started out
charging people and then you went
freemium right and so
that was a function of the money as well
yeah that allowed us to do yet at least
try frame him and see if that was a
model that would work which if you
weren't like I mean if you are doing
like freemium is a bad idea generally
from bootstraps companies because like
you're going to have a ton of support
for free users who don't pay you
anything and if you're not getting any
money from them it's going to be really
hard to bootstrap so yeah like allowed
us to experiment with a business model a
little bit okay and so why did you
choose to not continue to raise money I
mean we never needed to was is the the
pragmatic answer and I think we've
always taken a very like pragmatic
approach to fundraising you know a lot
of people have this you know it's like
well it's either bootstrap or you know
or it's like VC and there's like some
identity involved in it which I think
when you like start to put your own
identity and like well I'm a
bootstrapper I'm a VC thing like that
starts to affect your decision-making in
ways that are probably not healthy for
your company and it's just better to
look at money and fundraising generally
as as like a tool it's a tool in your
tool belt that you can use if you need
it if you don't need it you don't need
to you shouldn't have to use it so
that's how our approach to fundraising
always was was it's just a tool to help
you if you need it if you don't need it
then why take on the dilution and so for
us was we we were able to figure out the
business model and we our growth rates
were working just fine and we've never
been hindered by our ability to spend
capital we've always felt like we're
spending at a rate that was comfortable
for us so bringing in more capital
wasn't going to change fundamentally
change like our ability to grow the
company so we always said well we'll
just keep growing it how we're going in
and so then I imagine you get a lot of
questions from people who are like
should I raise money should I not raise
money what should I do
what are your do you have like a mental
model to advise people on that well you
know I think it's it's a pretty personal
decision to me the answer is generally
like what is the business market you're
tackling right there's some products
that yeah probably going to lend itself
more towards that
like you know pure enterprise plays
sometimes take a little while to develop
and you're going to need more capital
ops games things that require like
inventory or infrastructure things like
that are going to be capital intensive
so sometimes
fundraising is really just a function of
the market that you decide to go after
so that plays into it but then also it
does depend on like how how you want to
go about things like you can be a
successful bootstrap company and be the
winner of your market you look at
something like MailChimp which having to
raised a single dime they have dozens of
well-funded super well-funded public
companies that are direct competitors
and still Mel Jim takes the takes the
takes it home as the the winner of that
market so there's a lot of these phrases
that people say like Oh winner-take-all
money Marky you better raise a bunch of
money they're just kind of untrue you
really need to like look at your market
and just understand it really well and
you know fundraising can help you create
a moat but usually it's not why you
created a moat having more money doesn't
necessarily make the moat it is a tool
to help you figure out what is the most
it's going to help you build your
company and if money isn't the thing
that's going to help you do it you need
to figure out what is going to help you
kind of build your moat and help you
grow your company and so then how do you
how do you better I mean define like a
winner take all market for sure like why
was MailChimp you know possible well so
like MailChimp isn't in a
winner-take-all right Marty right like
there's not a network effect that you
know MailChimp doesn't get better
because there's more MailChimp customers
right winner-take-all markets tend to
exist where the product gets better
because there's more customers and this
often often happens in like b2c market
though you know like Google gets better
because more people use Google Facebook
gets better because all your friends use
Facebook
those are like classic examples of
network effects really helping the
product get better and the business
model doesn't really work unless
everybody is kind of using it whereas in
b2b like it's pretty rare to have like
true winner-take-all markets you know if
you're making yet another CRM company
you know there's there's dozens of CRM
companies that are very good CRM
companies that compete with each other
head-to-head
and are all successful and they're going
to continue to grow and be successful
and that's pretty much how it exists in
b2b because it's very tough to build
like true Network effects in b2b so if
you can find a way to like have a b2b
company that has true network offense
that's probably going to be a pretty
special thing okay and it's worth worth
trying to figure one out but it's not a
necessity to build a good company mmm
and so looking back on I'm kind of like
using YC as a vehicle into the bay was
that helpful for you or yeah definitely
you know I remember early on we had a
relatively big company that we were
trying to build a partnership with and
there was update a bit more like
bureaucracy and hoops to jump through to
build a partnership with versus a lot of
the companies we were working with at
the time and you know we just kind of
tried to go through like their typical
front you know they had a email or
contact form on their website like we
filled it out and we were just like not
making any headway at all that way it
was just you know we I think we got in
touch with one other like front line
people and they just didn't understand
what we were doing or why it even
mattered and you know kind of just set
us to the side and then we tried another
angle and it just just things weren't
happening and then we got into I see one
of the first things I did was you know
email the folks in PGA was like oh yeah
we can help with that and found a you
know like a company they'd acquired like
their CEO and like I had an intro to
like a high level VP like in two days
and you know that week it was like oh
yeah this is great we should definitely
be doing something with this so you know
though that those relationships clearly
matter in business and YC had already
tapped in and kind of set up its own and
and it had connections into the broader
tech ecosystem you know helped us plug
in and be successful because it existed
hmm and so that what do you advise
founders who are starting companies you
know in Missouri or you know in other
countries yeah what do you tell them
what are your tips well I think you know
the biggest thing is similar what you
all preach all day every day which is
you know make something people want
right so figure out you know what it is
that people want figure out what they're
going to pay for and just make them
incredibly happy
and you don't necessarily well there's
no where does it like there's so many
companies that are successful that are
outside the Bay Area that I think if
you're getting caught up and you know if
people are telling you have to be in the
barrier to be successful like you should
probably be a little more critical of
that advice because it's there's so many
examples that are just unlike that not
being true pay attention to the
fundamental things that make companies
really good which is good products happy
customers and like working really hard
and getting a little lucky like those
are generally like the four things if
you do those pretty well like you're
going to have some level success you may
not be like a breakaway success because
a lot of that stuff depends on like
timing and Morlock and market and
factors and things like that but
generally if you do those four things
you'll be successful some companies may
be more successful in the Bay Area
because of unique factors for that
company but I think those are fewer and
far between than most companies mm-hmm
it seems to be more of a psychological
thing right because like people have
this somewhat of an impostor syndrome
where they're like oh we can't be that
but in reality most companies aren't
venture-backed anyway yeah well I think
um one of the things that you know
perpetuates this myth a little bit is
just kind of the way the media cycle
what works is you know the media tends
to write about companies that they think
are doing great it's very difficult for
the media to get access to real factual
data like revenue numbers to know which
companies are doing great and so they
end up having to rely on proxies for
that and a good proxy often is you know
whereas the venture funded companies
happening and venture funding companies
have tend to happen closest to where VCS
happen to live because they don't like
to travel that much to go fund companies
and so that tends to be very companies
and so the media ends up perpetuating
kind of this myth that the great
companies are in the valley that's
obviously on you know there's a lot of
stereotypes involved that's not
universally true but on the whole that
happens quite a bit and you know an
early a young founder someone who's a
first-time sound
under you know for them they don't have
that filter to understand sometimes like
what is good advice versus what someone
perpetuating kind of a myth hmm and as
being here change your product all that
much because you guys started out
basically consulting for other people
you were doing these integrations by
hand yep and then you're like oh what if
we just made it easier for everyone to
do all these integration from a product
standpoint I know it's not changed it
okay and so what has changed since being
here and I mean those relationships
right and we mentioned the end of the YC
connection you know from Forgetting in
with that partnership with a big company
that was nice you know we've been able
to build relationships with you know
founders of our partner companies a lot
easier and that was more valuable early
on but as we kind of built a brand and
got to a place where we had a bit of
success like that stuff came to us
naturally so at this point in time like
you know I could be in the Bay Area it
could be somewhere else and it would
just really wouldn't matter too much and
then how do you guys think about
competitors is like you've said you know
you could have built this company with
that necessarily raising any money yep
that means other people might be able to
jump on and do the same thing yeah yeah
what do you guys look out for well I
think the biggest thing is like figure
out what you're like competitive
advantages and find ways to lock them
out so for us you know we have the most
integrations of anyone and most of our
partners are building the integrations
for us and so that kind of built a bit
of a moat for us in that you know if you
want to you know build a head-to-head
you know
competitor to us you need to find a way
to build as many integrations as we have
you know there or you need to find a
different way to attack us like coming
head-to-head wouldn't be the way to do
it so like it for most people it's
figuring out what it is that makes you
like makes you're you're the reason why
people choose your product look what is
it the reason that they choose your
product and like use that to help lock
out other folks and then make sure that
you are indeed the best product and
value on the market for your your
customers that you want to serve right
and so where do you see your product
evolving so it continues to have a wider
moat well for us like you know we've
historically nailed our like our best
customers have been in SMB and so we've
done a really good job there now we're
working a lot harder on you know we
launched a team's product in March and
so we're starting to figure out like
what are the things that we need to do
to help expand our adoption inside of
like enterprise companies and things
like that because the needs are the core
product works for them but there's extra
needs that are important in enterprise
products and stuff like that so you know
those are things that we start to think
about and how do you explain it to like
as a small business you know if you have
someone like sort of technical on the
team it's pretty easy to get like okay
this is what that beer does yeah wake up
right if you're selling to a giant
company how do you have to explain it to
them and who do you explain it to yeah
to get them to buy it well that stuff
this is where like you know having a
product that solves like a very specific
problem helps and this is where the
freemium business model helps a lot
because people can self-serve try out
your products figure out what they like
about it and then you can use the person
who's already adapted it is a way into
your organization and they can be like
your champion for you and that way you
don't have to be like cold selling into
orgs instead you have a warm person on
the inside that's basically saying no no
this is great we should adopt this this
is exactly what we need so I think
that's where you know freemium really
does excel if you can make pull it off
it will help you get that early adoption
into organizations that can then pull
you across the organization as well you
know
conversely what's been difficult about
getting into these enterprises well I
mean there's just like a lot of
bureaucracy around it right and I'm
older and right so the same old stuff
you know they have purchasing
departments and they have process that
you have to go through and there's just
you know think boxes a lot of boxes to
check more or less when it boils down to
right
okay so Matt had another question is
another location question actually so
what advice do you have for a founder
who's building a billion dollar company
in a city where no one has done it
for uh I mean the the biggest challenge
I mean I this is tough for me because I
haven't built a bike company yet either
so but my instinct is that the thing
that you're going to struggle with maybe
is as you're scaling past that mark is
does that city have enough talent to
support your organization and that can
be a real challenge in smaller cities
across the United States is like do you
have the like is there enough technical
talent is there enough sales talent can
you train if not can you have effective
training programs in your organization
that can take you know ambitious folks
and get them trained up on your product
and turn them into people who can can be
effective in your organization because
when you just like look at the unit
economics of a town that's maybe you
know a hundred thousand two hundred
thousand people like that's just not
that many people and a lot of them are
maybe not necessarily going to be in the
industry that you're in so as you get to
a billion dollar organization you're
going to need a lot of people to help
you and is there enough there so I think
that's probably the the biggest scaling
challenges you might actually just run
into if you're the first in a city of a
billion dollars or a billion dollar
company is just there the talent there
and how do you manage I mean really how
do you manage training people up
remotely because like are you because
you have kind of pick across the whole
world you instead focus on hiring more
experienced people or do you grab
younger people and like bring them up
our preference has definitely been
historically to just work with senior
folks like we just hire the best that we
can for different roles but you're going
to find like even still you're going to
hire ambitious folks who want to get
better and want to take on new
challenges you're going to want to find
ways to handle that so like for example
you know we hire ambitious folks in
Dorset fourteen who often have
experience and our senior for that role
yeah but oftentimes they still have even
bigger ambitions still so you know one
of our guys who just recently joined our
platform engineering team started in
support and
you know he had ambitions to do that and
so we made sure that you know his man
his manager knew that and we made sure
an engineering manager knew that and we
kind of had a plan like okay well here's
the tactical skills your needs going to
need to learn here's the things inside
the org that you can when you see these
opportunities go make sure that you're
the first person you know trying to
tackle these things and helping out with
these things here's the things external
that you can learn on your own time it's
going to make this stuff a little easier
for you and you know these are the
benchmarks that will let you know like
you're ready to make that jump
so maybe we just like worked with them
to figure out like here's here's the
plan that you need to set up and you
know from there it's kind of on on the
person to you know go make it happen and
he was able to make it happen and joined
our platform engineering team earlier
this year I think that's like just a
discussion you need to have with every
person that's on your team it's just
understand like hey what are your career
goals what do you want to achieve while
you're here are their skills that you
want to pick up are there you know areas
of the organization that you want to
have an impact on and then as a manager
like figuring out like okay how can we
make sure that this person has an
opportunity to tackle that stuff in a
way that aligns with the projects that
we need to make the organizational
successful and is that like public in
any way within the organization is like
you know these are your objectives and
goals for this year uh we haven't gotten
like super rigid about like you know
okay ours or creepy eyes or things like
that we do have them but they're you
know each manager talks with our you
know person on their team and they you
know directly and set them up kind of
for them and so they're a little bit
fluid and we're working on like
solidifying like a process for that
because I do think it's a good idea well
because you guys yeah yeah everything
seems to have to be clearly communicated
and logged right so it doesn't like slip
between the cracks because you know say
I'm going for one thing and you don't
know it and maybe my manager is cool
with it but you're like why is Craig
doing this in the corner right like guy
doing
okay so yeah still working on that and
then how how does that all effect like
retention do you guys have how does your
attention like benchmark to you know
like a tech company out here our
attention is like incredibly high so we
actually just ran the numbers last week
and like ninety seven percent retention
for over the last twelve months okay all
right we did we started doing like an
employee Net Promoter Score and came in
at like 72 which is like pretty
world-class so I think you know working
on your organization is like a really
really important thing to do because
past a certain point like you aren't
going to be the person that's the
building the product and getting things
done you sure you'll provide some
certain amount of vision and direction
to make some of that happen but a lot of
the actual work is being done by other
folks in your organization so you really
do need to make sure to invest in them
and you know put them up in an
environment where they can be successful
and so that's like primary a lot of what
I try and work on is make sure they're
the right people network that they're
working on the right things and that
they have the right plans in place for
them to be successful just as people too
well so yeah then how do you keep track
of like that the happiness of people on
like a day to day our week to week month
to month yes I mean the survey is like
kind of the formal way that we've
started doing it but a lot of it is just
comes down a relationship between like
manager and the person so you know they
do like a weekly one-on-one with them
system taken in and like how things
going like you know you feel like you're
getting to work on the things that you
want to work on you feel like you're
advancing they have some of those types
of questions and then if we do other
things too just like encourage like you
know good cross company called
communication camaraderie stuff like
that so we have we just thing called
pair buddies so every week you randomly
get paired up with someone across the
organization you'll just jump on like a
video conference call and talk to them
like you're kind of like a you know like
a coffee outing I guess that you might
do it
and another org you know just talk about
whatever right it doesn't have to be
work specific it's super informal and
talk about family hobbies whatever right
that helps folks get to know each other
and then we're like not very restrictive
about like off-topic stuff in slack
we're kind of okay with that because in
normal organizations like people are
going to have like water cooler talk and
like talk at lunch and all that sort of
stuff
it's like that's fine that stuff should
people should have a place for that
inside of a remote organization so we
have like a series of slack channels
that are prefixed with fun that tend to
just be like off-topic channels when
people do whatever and then every now
and then like people come up with like
random things so like I think a couple
weeks ago someone on our support team
wanted to do like is the end of Friday
afternoon on like Pacific time zones
like everybody in the company is
basically it's it's like soon to be or
almost weekend time and they're like
let's do like a random gift dance party
and so they like picked a random song
from Spotify somehow and then we're like
alright here's the song now like make a
gift of yourself like dancing to this
thing it's like about a dozen people
like uploaded random gifts greatest lack
that we're just you know for this song
so it's just like stuff like that we try
not like we we don't want to take
ourselves too seriously it's like this
is like a place where you can enjoy
yourself to a little bit like let's get
our stuff done and enjoy our time here
right totally
and so um so I guess slightly going off
topic like almost every interview I've
listened to or seen with you is like
remote work it's like not raising money
it's very location about stuff what's
something that you don't often talk
about that you're like passionate about
maybe it's within zap here maybe it's
not I think that there's probably like a
one thing I don't often talk about is
like like learning a lot and really like
speed as a way to learn things like
really going deep on a topic so
everything I do I try and do like really
really well to give you an example so I
started playing racquetball like prob
about two and a half years ago now I was
playing
College a little but just like for fun
and then I realized about you know two
years in two or three years in his app
year I like had stopped exercise and I
was starting to put on some weight like
you know founder 15 though in my case it
might have been 20 or 25 it was like all
right let me get this under control so
let's start playing racquetball actually
it's like yeah I was like oh I actually
enjoyed doing this it's like okay now
how can I once you start getting into is
like this is good exercise I actually
want to be good at this it's like how
can I be get to where I'm as good as I
possibly can be as quickly as I can and
I think a lot of folks spend a lot of
time when they're first learning
something trying to be like perfect at
it they're like I want to figure out all
the things that I could possibly need to
know about this instead of just getting
in and trying to like what are the few
things that I can get better on each
each day and so you know this for me
with racquetballs like alright I need to
just play a lot that's like the biggest
thing so I started playing like three or
four times a week I found a coach that
like was teaching me a few things and
like every time I would get out once a
week he would teach me one new thing and
it was like all right I'm just going to
practice that one new thing when I'm out
playing with folks it didn't even matter
so it was like this is the shot I'm
going to take even if that wasn't the
right shot to take in that moment was
like I'm going to make that shot anyway
because I'm just going to keep working
on it and I think this kind of like
approach to learning really helps in all
sort rying to learn so like this is
something I hope talked to life for
everyone who's joining our support team
I'm like look you know out the gate
you're going to know like next to
nothing about what you need to do the
biggest way you can get better is not by
writing a perfect answer to this one
ticket but it's trying to do as many
tickets as you possibly can in a given
day because if you're able you know out
the gate to answer 20 emails a day for
the first week well at the end of the
week you've done 100 emails versus the
person who only does you know five a day
they've only done 25 so now you have you
know seventy five more interactions of
learning than the person who only did
five so it's like if you can get you
know enough like reps in basically
that's going to really accelerate your
learning so I think a lot of folks spend
too much time on
being perfect perfectionist about things
and they forget like a lot of times if
you just do it enough times you're just
going to get better at it because you've
done it a lot so that's like a one thing
that I think is like a lot of founders
could could really learn from it's just
like don't worry about trying to be
perfect just try a bunch of stuff like
just do a lot of things and you're going
to get better at it
mmm that's great advice in there because
there's there's often such little
downside yeah like especially in
software like maybe you're shooting up
rockets and that's one yeah right but
like you know if you miss a line of form
or something matter and early on right
you have barely any customers like
whatever right like you know and you'll
figure it out right like it's not going
to be the end of the world you'll have
another opportunity to do something else
are you trying to learn anything else
right now oh I'm still trying to get
better racquetball but that's a big one
and then I mean I'm always trying to
like be a better CEO right like I think
that's been like a big transition for
like the last years like there's a
certain point where you stop being like
a founder and a part of the team and
you're like actually now I need to start
thinking about like me as a CEO and like
a leader of the organization and making
sure that like we're setting ourselves
up for a good future and so that's
something like I'm always like learning
and trying to get better at in fact one
of the things that I always like I like
to do is about every six months I'll go
seek out founders who are basically a
year ahead of me and just ask like what
what did you do in your last year like
what was the smartest thing you did in
last year what was the dumbest thing you
didn't last year like what are the
things that you're really happy about
what are the things you regret and that
kind of helps paint a picture of what's
to come for me and so that way I can
sometimes you can preamp some of it or
and sometimes you can't sometimes it's
just like you know alright yeah that
it's like you just know like it's coming
right well okay yeah share some with
them what do you expect what's coming
down the pike well you know I think you
know one of the interesting things I've
heard from other folks is you know as
you scale your organization you know you
get past 100 people you're going to
realize like the folks that got you
there might not get you to the next
level
and that's not anything inherently good
or bad and the people that you've worked
with that's just something that I think
a lot of folks have realized like some
people thrive in smaller organizations
some people are better bigger
organizations and there are there is a
Venn diagram overlap where people are
successful in both and can scale go the
distance but that's not always the case
and so thanks that's the thing that you
know we've been lucky to have really
good retention rate but it'll be
interesting to see like how far out we
can push that you know given that this
kind of phenomenon exists where like
people you know end up going out so
they're like decide like I just like
being in smaller organizations so like
that's one thing that I've kind of got
like in the back of my head or my heart
and how are you going to like you know
handle some of this stuff that's great I
guess my well yeah I guess my last
question is then like what are your pro
racquetball tips oh my goodness
probably racquetball I don't know
anything about racquetball so uh get
fine like find like the old guy at the
gym like he's like 60 or 70 you're going
to think he's like not very good and
then get on the court with them and then
he'll smoke you and then ask him like
how did you beat me so bad and the
reality is like the guy is probably
played for like you know two three four
decades and knows exactly what he needs
to do to like even if you're young and
fast and athletic like it doesn't matter
like you're not going to beat them
because racquetball actually there is
like quite a bit of strategy in it you
can't just like unlike if you're a
first-time you're not going to like out
athlete like a guy who's played for a
while even if they do have like bad
knees and like a relationship and they
don't really move around yeah it's like
they don't have to you because they just
know where to hit the ball that you're
not going to get to it oh I know and I
you know I think that applies to a lot
of things like you especially you know
in startups if things are moving fast
and growing fast like find someone that
just can help you right like and has
been there and done that like they're
going to know they just like know where
all the trapdoors are and like we're all
that the hidden things that are going to
trip you up are and so you know they may
not know a hundred percent of the things
that you're going to run into
but they can be a good resource for you
and just accelerate your learning a
little bit so you know once you have an
opportunity to like get that kind of
mentorship or help or whatever like find
a find a person that can can be that for
you great all right thanks for coming in
yeah awesome Thanks
you